russland hat eine ungeheure brutale
kriegsweise geht aber auch und jetzt
kommt der Punkt ungeheuer brutal mit den
eigenen Soldaten um wir hören auch heute
früh wieder die Russen verwenden ihre
Soldaten schlecht ausgebildet als ein
furchtbarer Begriff Entschuldigung dafür
Kanonenfutter um das ständig zu machen
die Ukrainer verteidigen mit einem
Bruchteil der Truppen dort und halten
das und das müssen wir doch unterstützen
denn ansonsten dringen die 200 oder
300.000 Soldaten durch zweiter Aspekt
die russischen Truppen sind nicht nur
schlecht ausgebildet sie sind auch
schlecht motiviert sie ersetzen Menge
durch wie soll ich sagen sie ersetzen
Intelligenz und kluge Operationsführung
durch Masse und da kann die Ukraine
wirklich gegenhalten
[Musik]